Hi.
My name is Dwayne Lessner.
I'm a Technical Marketing Engineer
at Nutanix.
And here with me-
>> I'm Karl Krueger.
I'm a Course Developer here at Udacity.
Welcome to our course
on Intro to DevOps.
>> We'll take you through what
makes up the principles of DevOps,
explain how to apply
them where you work, and
showcase some tools that can
help you along your journey.
>> We'll start out by talking about
what DevOps is, where it came from, and
what problems it's trying to solve.
>> We'll dive into what makes dev and
ops people tick.
How to understand the other side,
gain some empathy.
And how they are motivated to get
to the end goal of creating better
work flows to save you time, and
to keep you from pulling your hair out.
>> And we'll talk about some tools for
those work flows.
Deployment, automation, and
monitoring tools that can really change
your working environment for the better.
Throughout we'll sprinkle
in some examples.
We'll also take a look on how we can
measure the benefit of dev ops in use.
>> So with that let's get into it.